I will donate one sub per move you don't
move the king
up to 50 Subs that's that sounds
actually doable
I'm back in the tournament
sounds very doable if I don't move the
king it's just no casting chess
I took photos today at us us Champs
there's a photo that went viral
yesterday that was taken by Leonard
and I I actually I ended up getting a
summer shot today
of the Arbiters scanning the bandana
it's uh yeah it creates some interesting
photo opportunities
okay
we'll see how this goes I'm gonna play a
London
because there's lines in the London
where
I don't Castle the king
oh don't play this line please don't
I'm actually wondering
no I think the sign is fine
there are certain lines where I I have
to move the king if we go deep into
Theory
okay I'm happy to see this line oh this
is a fun line
I've had this position many times before
my phone's not falling for the main trap
the Trap is Bishop D6 Bishop A6
so I think I've still played Knight 95.
hello Mr Rosen
hello MW welcome back
I think Asics is one of the best moves
there like preventing Bishop B5 but
it's still interesting
and I am following like most opening
principles in this game
now London is one of those openings it's
hard not to follow opening principles
controlling the center developing
Knights and Bishop
I guess I did develop a bishop of our
Knights
okay
I mean do I want to win a pawn
Maybe
but maybe not
maybe like F3
the problem with winning a pawn is like
the file is exploited later
although I couldn't I could play this
first actually
like Bishop B5 Rook C and then win the
pawn
maybe I'll do that
I'm Bishop B5 is a nice looking move
exploiting the PIN
and this Pawn is overworked
yeah I want to take here but
I think I should take with uh the bishop
and then
take on E6 with the Rook
now C6 is a target
and it's very tempting to take this Pawn
I don't think that's any good though
because after it takes takes the bishop
moves magnet gets trapped
I'm trying to evaluate Knight C6
which looks a bit more promising
there's some line where the C file opens
I'm considering to take your first
and then something like B4 and
eventually win C6
wow
okay how is this Rook gonna get in if
I'm not moving my king
I think I played B4
B4 okay five
this bishop actually does a really nice
job
um controlling the B file
so after Rook 8 Rook here takes change
there's no Rook V8 even if there was I
would have B4
okay now I have this move
I think at some point I'll play F3 and
maybe expand
like so far there hasn't even been a
reason to move my king
I think overall I've just been playing
like
as I would normally
play this move
I'm scared my opponent will realize a
challenge in Sac on F2
I like this move though
I just want to play H3 next
okay there is rookie here but then takes
and then Knight A5
to keep the file closed
wow
I'm guess I'll take the Knight
something like F3
also considering F4
3 looks fine
okay
I've made it to move 21 so far
no casting
uh rookie seven
or okay one
uh the bishop wants to go to C4
here okay seven though
uh
let's play rookie one
so I'm up two Pawns
thank you to Club
to seeb says what if I said double Subs
if you win without ever moving the king
that would be difficult but maybe doable
I mean I'm gonna try at least for the
next
20 to 30 moves
I think I have to trade Rooks
and Knight A5
but most end games like you you need
your kingdom man
okay so G4 and Rook H2 is one plan
the problem is I can't play G4 right
away because
f8
so I think I play Rook H2 first
maybe I play G3
G3 Rook f8
F4
that's probably the way to go
okay things are opening up a little bit
uh that's not the move I wanted to see
wow there's a crazy line
right
okay so the line I'm calculating is
takes Rook F3
C4
uh
and how crazy do I want to go here
it's about B3
which might be a move
b3z4
B3 might be the way to go
ideas to play C4 next
or I'll move 30 I haven't moved my king
I still have castling rights
oh it's kind of funny
when the Bishops tied down to the pawn
kind of I mean there is this
takes takes
I think you asvine demion
oh this is a tournament yeah if you're
just joining this is a classical Shield
Arena
it's a long classical tournament on the
chess
attention to play this move now
and now this move
oh dear
I'm still holding off
now I can take
how to do this
I don't want to risk losing that's the
problem
okay so I'm over defending the pawn I
want to take here next
now here
idea this
I'm resisting King E2
I'm going full anti-vungalow
okay now this move
hmm
is that actually crazy like the the
resulting position
[Music]
I don't know if I can win without the
king
but we're going pretty deep into the end
game
and King is actually really well placed
on E1 now
take
I'll come back Stephen James to believe
this is all a ploy to make him think
your king can't move until eventually
said King does Move Like an action hero
in a movie and eliminates all of the
enemy pieces in your choreographed fight
sequence
that would be an epic finale
I gotta play C5 here
C5 King D7
or I move 37
oh I didn't not see that move I have
this move though it might be Knight B3
is really my only option
and now I'm threatening Knight D4
the king is tied down to D7
I'm trying to get to move 50.
okay let's check
maybe this move
I mean this is winning though takes King
E2 it's winning but
let's burn a few moves
wait a minute
I could make the pawn advance
um
yeah this is where the fun begins
on move 40.
it's actually really interesting to try
and win this without moving the king
I don't think it's possible though
I mean I'll try though
because these pawns are fully blockaded
that's a good move
play this move
oh no my knight
oh no my knight
someone call an ambulance
I see if I could play this and it's
repetition 26 months oh yeah Eric have
you watched any anime yet not yet
okay I have this move now
ah there's a nice idea
play this move here and then here and
then here it takes takes and then the
horse cannot be saved yeah take the
horse
the horse is gonna do the saving
okay I'm winning this Pawn now
don't mess with my horsey
okay how do I
let me do this
I mean I still have this funny move
oh no my horsey
yeah so this is hit and now the the plan
is to maneuver
to C6
or um F3
eventually maybe the C6
I don't know if I've ever done this
before
I probably have actually
a point resigns before move 50.
I was gonna say this could be a cool
rosenrophy to win a game without moving
the king
I've definitely won games
before maybe not quite like this
whoa to see gifting a hundred Subs
thanks so much to seebs
now that was a fun challenge I'll have
to put this on YouTube
you did win the game without moving the
king
yeah
you can zoom through the game
it's like one of those time lapses of a
building
where the building just stays stationary
and the clouds just fly by and the whole
scenery changes around us
oh
foreign